for rufus an overseas student commuting
from derby to birmingham city university
the rail strike doesn't just mean
missing college it might imperil his
visa if i can't get to college it's
going to affect my attendance
and i might run into problems with um uk
border and enforcement because
attendance is part of
my eligibility to be in the country
there will be millions of tales of
inconvenience this week when the biggest
national rail strike in 30 years goes
ahead last-ditch talks collapsing in
acrimony unions blaming government for
tying the hands of rail companies we
have kept up
called your relationships with the
employers all the way through this but
what we have got come to understand
is that the dead hand of this tory
government is all over this dispute
and the fingerprints of grant shaps and
the dna of rishi sunak
all over
the problems on the railway and indeed
the problems in this society and until
they allow these employers
to negotiate freely i can't see that
we're going to get a settlement
in a dispute over paying conditions rmt
members including guards catering staff
and signalers are asking for a seven
percent pay rise network rail which is
publicly owned offered two percent plus
another one per cent conditional on a
restructuring plan that could cut two
and a half thousand jobs and require
changes to working hours the government
announced a change to the law that will
allow agency workers to cover for
striking staff the transport secretary
saying rail workers owe the public for
support during the pandemic we put 16
billion pounds of taxpayers money in
that's the equivalent of 600 pounds per
household in the country to support
railway workers this is how the unions
are thanking the public by going on
strike at the first opportunity they get
before the negotiations uh have even
been have even taken place london will
also see a tube strike on tuesday
leaving dismay away from the blame game
i've got a work trip um i can go up
today
and tomorrow's obviously the strike i
don't know whether i'll be able to get
home whether it's rain the trains are
going in the right place i don't drive
so
as a zero hour contract basically if i
don't work i don't get paid so every
time they go on strike i end up losing
money passengers should expect severe
disruption
it'll be a very limited service only
about 20 percent of services will be
running and only on about half the
network so please check before you
travel and if you can avoid traveling
tomorrow then please do
unions say they're fighting for everyone
affected by the cost of living crisis
but this dispute also has its roots in
the pandemic
kobe 19 undermined the business model of
the railways and it's left the
state-owned network rail which manages
stations like this battling to rebalance
the books for a future that may have
fewer passengers just as the government
takes greater control of the network
through a new body great british
railways which will set theirs and
negotiate directly with staff including
train drivers who aren't even striking
this week that's why neither ministers
or unions want to back down
there may not be a train at your
platform tomorrow but another dispute
may be along shortly
paul kelso sky news in birmingham